you boys dipping like dip yes like in a
lip excuse me
two different podcasts oh I did are you
getting like Ranch dark spicy mayo there
we go there we go you guys are Dippers
[Music]
we get criticized man and yeah crucified
sometimes man for a difference amount of
dips but one time this guy just got I
could tell he's getting frustrated with
how many lines he was making this
notepad you flip the sheet just a lot of
sauces and he forgot one for which one
the honey mustard not tip him no I don't
know I forgot that's it
that's the rule I'm just laughing at him
like like walking away like he's he
thinks he has your order and you're like
no no player you turn them around and
you flip his paper back you're like you
forgot the sauce page you're not even
looking at it